critics of texas governor greg abbott
say he's playing politics with his
proposal
that the state built its own border wall
yesterday he said texas would spend
250 million dollars on a down payment
for the project
but the governor's plan announced at the
state capitol is still light on
specifics
it's not clear if it's legal maria
villarreal is in austin maria the
federal government
originally estimated its border wall
would cost more than 21 billion dollars
so can the state afford this
good morning anthony right now the
governor just didn't have those
details he doesn't really know how long
the project will take he doesn't know
how much it will cost right now
and really he doesn't know exactly how
much of the wall can actually be built
here
in texas what he does know is that in
addition to that 250 million
taxpayer dollars that they've already
set aside they will also
crowdsource this wall and they're asking
people to send in donations here
to the state capitol in austin as you
said a lot of people feel like this is a
political move
and that is very frustrating to the
people we have talked to down on the
border
that are already exhausted by this
immigration politics
i'm 76 years old and i've seen
migrants all my life coming through the
cabazos family has owned
this land along the texas-mexico border
for generations
when we visited reykjavasu's anzaldua in
2019
they were battling the federal
government to keep their land intact
since then they've lost six and a half
acres it's very easy
to be sitting in your living room
and they say oh yeah i built a damn wall
built to them walk they're not losing
anything
we're losing on wednesday texas governor
greg abbott
demanded the federal government return
land that was supposed to go towards
trump's now defunded federal wall
so texas can use that land and build a
wall of its own
the federal government has a legal
responsibility under the federal
immigration laws to do it
but because they are not doing it texas
taxpayers are having to step up
so that we as a state
can protect our citizens he sees a real
opportunity here to be a national
republican leader on this issue
patrick's v-tech covers state politics
for the texas tribune
he says abbott may have his eyes on a
presidential run in 2024.
is this about bigger aspirations and
bigger political aspirations
i think what today was about was him
taking his most drastic action yet to
show
to republican primary voters that he is
the person who wants to
in some ways continue the legacy of
donald trump in four years the trump
administration
only managed to build 52 miles of new
structures on the border
with some sections costing as much as 46
million dollars per mile how do you
respond to people who say that this is
more of a political ploy anyone who
thinks this is politics
doesn't have a clue what's going on in
the border it's political theater that's
what it is i'm not for open borders
the problem is in the united states
until you can reduce the demand
for illegal immigration and illegal
drugs
this is going to continue
not only are the details of this
particular project still very unclear
but so is the legal aspect of
all of this the biden administration
defunded the federal wall
program just last week and right now it
seems like governor abbott's plan is in
direct
contrast to federal immigration laws we
have spoken with legal experts that say
in the past the supreme court has highly
sided with the federal government
when it comes to immigration enforcement
tony
a lot of unknowns remain maria thank you
very much